hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra's never seen and today
I am watching the most highly
recommended film for Tamra's never seen
click I've seen it I know everyone's
going to blaze in the comments already I
have seen clue I saw clue when I was six
years old at my next-door neighbor
Amanda's house and I remember enjoying
the out of it I remember attending and
being like dang I was funny
it's funny I've not seen it since then
though and I feel like it's the most
requested Tambor's never seen an episode
even though I've said hundreds of times
that I've seen it before have seen the
alien movies I have seen clue I have
seen Spaceballs I have seen that
Princess Bride those are ones that I get
asked to do a lot so I figured I turn it
into an episode I think it'll be really
fun to talk about this is the first time
that I've done this on this series
Tamra's never seen but she has she's
seen it she's seen it contrary to
popular belief
she's definitely seen that she's lying
of course I'm dressed up like a
second-rate Madeline Kahn it's coming
you know the flames bit is going you
know I'm gonna do okay
I have husbands to kill so let's do this
[Music]
you
okay that was what what what what what
what what such a different movie as an
adult again I don't remember that much
from it when I first saw I remember the
physical comedy really landing but I
don't remember the Giants plethora of
adult jokes it's I don't remember there
being a gay character he turns out to
not be gay and the final ending I
mentioned the gay character because I
was not at all shown any kind of any
entertainment or any kind of content any
kind homosexuality I watched all three
endings for this one as well I know that
when it first came out only certain
endings were playing at certain theaters
it's like the Pirates of Caribbean for
board games you know like it's something
that you kind of grew up with did they
try to make spin-offs like when the
Pirates of the Caribbean came out was so
popular Disney was like wow let's make
Haunted Mansion and then it was like a
flock were there other board games that
came out are there other board game
movies like operation that just what the
human centipede is it opens and you see
all these characters assembling together
for this party and they've all been
asked to come and they've all been given
different names to go by and we've seen
this before it's like and and then there
were none the book by Agatha Christie is
all the characters that we know from the
game the game that I definitely cheated
on every time that I played it sorry
Taylor my little brother and sister it
was it was it was Professor plum in the
kitchen with the wrench I don't know how
I got it on the second turn either looks
crazy they get a letter inviting them to
Hill House don't go there don't go there
and then you get to see who's playing
who
mrs. white buy the best actress ever
Madeline Kahn I love her in everything
that she's in and
and Thank You Tamra's never seen for
really really introducing me to her I
know I mean I saw this when I was young
I saw her and other things but my god
alive is she wonderful and brilliant in
everything that she does
flames okay we'll get to that Tim Curry
is wodsworth is just delightful the best
he's so funny in this every line that he
delivers she's so dry
mr. plum played by Christopher Lloyd who
looks so much younger than another role
he played in the same year 1985 Doc
Brown holy hell man what a year for you
dude clue and back to the future that's
a dang year they're all so wonderful I
don't think there's a weak link among
them except possibly for the actor who
plays mr. Boddy in the beginning before
he dies I wrote mr. Boddy's blackmailing
them I don't love his acting though I
know I don't I don't there was something
off about him I know in the end it's
revealed he's the butler and that Tim
Curry is actually mr. Boddy
and I that makes a little more sense to
me I don't know it feels like he's
acting like being a bad actor that makes
sense he was just a different caliber
than the rest of the people I don't know
who he is
sorry if I'm offending anyone that's
just how I feel there's a scene after
dinner where they're all having brandy
there they're finding out why they're
all assembles there and it's because
they're being all blackmailed by mr.
Boddy and they reveal all of the bad
deeds they're being blackmailed for his
wife killed Oliver happens and peacock
is helping her
Alton husband miss Scarlett has a
business in prostitution and Colonel
Mustard is billionaire Baum and
professor plum he's kind of a blues
client students maybe and then mr. green
is just gay so they've all done
something really wrong they each get
gifts for mr. Boddy and it's all of the
famous weapons from the game and it's a
really great scene it's also pretty
unevenly matched with the
for weapons I got a candlestick oh I got
a gun you got it what you see mr.
Boddy's killed the cook is killed you
really get introduced to the maid now
and they're all running around splitting
up trying to find who is killing people
because cops are coming in a half hour
now that I was rewatching I remember the
physical comedy really hitting me hard
as a kid there's one line where Tim Cory
is like I'm not shouting I'm shouting
I'm shouting I sure want something hits
it on the head he falls hilarious comedy
gold but there are so many sexual jokes
that just went straight over little
innocent innocent Tamara's head this guy
gets stranded on the road and he shops
by to use the phone and then he dies
from some mysterious person that cop
comes investigating the car that was on
the road looking for the guy that's dead
in their house so he comes in to use the
phone and then he dies the maid is dead
now a singing telegram comes in she dies
dum de dum dum dum I am nursing ding
telegram I forget how it goes but it was
really cute it's all just hilarious
chaos it's hard to kind of react to it I
guess because it's just joke after joke
after joke after joke and I will say
here's maybe not a criticism but
something I noticed is it is so so much
slower the pacing of it is so much
slower for a comedy than what we get
today but the jokes are just all so good
and they hit so well they're subtle and
they just kind of quit by you and then
like two seconds later you're like oh my
god
hilarious or just get you immediately
slaps you in the face they're all just
so good and well done that you don't
mind the pacing it's just it's just
different than what you're used to Tim
Curry's character starts telling us what
has happens and he's figured it out and
he knows who murdered who and it's so
magical they're all running about the
house they go back to the very beginning
things we already we know what's
happened but it's so fun to relive it
through them all running and scattering
about first one is mrs. Scarlett you you
terrible woman here's how it could have
happened and the second one is mrs.
peacock you've wild bird but here's what
really happened then it was everyone
everyone but mr. green my favorite was
mrs. white obviously obviously miss
Madeline Kahn was the best mr. green in
the hallway with why would I why would
that be my first instinct my finger
where my hand is right next to the
trigger I could just usually just oh oh
it's a very cheap gun it's never do this
at home kids well uh it's such a good
movie it's so well done the acting is
incredible I don't know why I haven't
rewatched this already I don't know why
I haven't gone back and seen this again
because I remember really loving it as a
kid and so for me to be like ah no no
thank you
but Tamara why would you watch Cheetah
Girls 2 when you know that you love clue
you can just rewatch that no I think
I'll just watch the Cheetah Girls -
thank you very much it's a hard one to
talk about though cuz it's just joke
after joke after joke the jokes were all
so amazing they all stick out in my mind
but what do I talk about I mean I'm
gonna do the breathing heavy breathing
flames on keeping my face but what like
what do you talk about they're all so
well done I hope you guys enjoyed this I
really enjoyed touching upon it again I
know that there's a couple that I could
retouch up on home and we'll see if I do
that we'll see we'll see if everyone
gets upset that I've seen thank you so
much Raja I'll see you all next week
a man it-it-it flames flames flames on
the side of my face my breathing breath
heavy breathing
heaving I love you Madeline Kahn I
haven't seen any like Godfather Scarface
or mm what are those series they're all
they're all the same in my mind I don't
know what they are I'm gonna go have sex
with my wife
[Music]
[Applause]
you